a set of laptop prices are normally
distributed with a mean of 750
and a standard deviation of 60.
what proportion of laptop prices are
between 624
and 700 768 dollars so let's think about
what they are asking
so we have a normal distribution for the
prices so it would look something like
this
and this is just my hand-drawn sketch of
a normal distribution
so look something like this it should be
symmetric so i'm making it as symmetric
as i can hand draw it
and we have the mean
right in the center
so the mean
would be right there and that is seven
hundred and fifty dollars
they also tell us that we have a
standard deviation of sixty dollars
so that means one standard deviation
above the mean would be
roughly right over here and that would
be 750 plus sixty so that would be eight
hundred and ten dollars one standard
deviation below the mean would put us
right about there
and that would be seven fifty minus
sixty dollars which would be
six hundred and ninety dollars
and then they tell us
what proportion of laptop prices are
between six hundred twenty four dollars
and seven hundred and sixty eight
dollars
so
the lower bound
six 624 dollars that's going to actually
be
more than another standard deviation
less so that's going to be right around
here
so that is
and 768
would put us right at about
right at about there and once again this
is just a hand-drawn sketch
but that is
768. and so what proportion are between
those two values
so we want to find essentially the area
under this distribution between these
two values
the way we are going to approach it
we're going to figure out the z score
for 768. it's going to be positive
because it's above the mean and then
we're going to use a z table to figure
out what proportion is below 768. so
essentially going to figure out this
entire area we're even going to figure
out the stuff that's below 624 that's
what that z table will give us then
we'll figure out the z score for 624
that will be negative 2 point something
and we will use the z table again to
figure out the proportion that is less
than that
and so then we can subtract this red
area from the proportion that is less
than 768 to get this area in between
so let's do that let's figure out first
the z-score for
and then we'll do it for 624.
the z score
for 768 i'll write it like that is going
to be
768 minus 750
over the standard deviation over 60 so
this is going to be equal to 18
over
which is the same thing as 6
over let's see if we divide the
numerator to the denominator by 3
6 twentieths and this is the same thing
as zero
point three
zero so that is the z score for this
upper bound let's figure out what
proportion is less than that for that we
take out a z table get our z table
and let's see we want to get 0.30
and so this is 0.3 this first column and
we've done this in other videos this
goes up until the tenths place for our
z-score and then if we want to go to our
hundredths place that's what these other
columns give us but we're at 0.3
so we're going to be
in
this row
and our hundredths place is right over
here it's a zero so this is the
proportion that is less than
768 dollars so
0.6179
so 0.61
so now let's do the same exercise but do
it for the proportion that's below 624
dollars
the z score
for
624 is going to be equal to 624
minus the mean of 750
all of that over 60. and so what is that
going to be i'll get my calculator out
for this one don't want to make a
careless error
624 minus 750
is equal to
and then divide by
is equal to negative 2.1 so that lower
bound is 2.1 standard deviations below
the mean or you could say it has a
z-score of negative 2.1
is equal to negative 2.1
and so to figure out the proportion that
is less than that this red area right
over here we go back to our z table and
we'd actually go to the first part of
the z table
so same idea but this starts at negative
a z score of negative 3.4 3.4 standard
deviations below the mean but just like
we saw before this is our
zero hundredths one hundredth two
hundredth so on and so forth and we
wanna go to negative two point one we
could say negative two point one zero
just to be precise so this is going to
get us let's see negative 2.1 there we
go and so
we are
negative 2.1 and it's negative
2.10 so we have zero hundredths so we're
going to be right here on our table so
we see the proportion that is less than
624 is
.0179 or 0.0179
so 0.0179
and so if we want to figure out the
proportion that's in between the two we
just subtract this red area from this
entire
area the entire proportion that's less
than 768 to get what's in between
zero 0.6179
once again i know i keep repeating it
that's this entire area right over here
and we're going to subtract out what we
have in red minus
0.0179 so we're going to subtract this
out to get
0.6
so
if we want to give our answer to 4
decimal places it would be 0.6000
or another way to think about it is
exactly 60 percent is
between 624 and 768.